if I wonder what your goldfish is
thinking if it's secretly plotting to
kill you or if it wonders why the ocean
is so small the myth that fish have a
two-second memory has long been
dispelled and fish in fact have quite
long memory spans goldfish can remember
the color of a tube that dispensed them
food one year after they last saw it
other small fish can remember the person
who fed them by hand even after a
six-month break this is what the little
fish brain looks like and has circuits
similar to reptiles birds and mammals in
fact fish actually have quite a lot
going on in those little heads of theirs
tool use is seen as a sign of
intelligence and animals and yes some
fish use tools you might think surely
not stone tools and Spears but that
isn't too far from the truth Archer fish
squirt Jets of water and sex on plants
above the surface to knock them into the
water they can adjust the size of the
squirts to the size of the insect and
learn to shoot at moving targets several
species hold scholars and clams in their
mouths and smash them against the
surface of a rock using it as an anvil
to break them up fish are pretty
mathematical - ever heard of the
equivalence relation fish know that if a
is bigger than B and B is bigger than C
then that means that a must also be
bigger than C which is a fundamental
step in logic fish use this knowledge to
find which other fish are dominant one
of the coolest examples of fish
intelligence is the cleaner fish which
performs a service for client fishers
belonging to other species by removing
and eating their ectoparasites clients
can invite a cleaning session by
adopting a typical posture or by simply
remaining immobile near a cleaning
station they can even form queues while
do
so but cleaning sessions do not always
end up well because the cleaners are
sometimes tempted to cheat and eat the
nutritious body mucus of their clients
something that often makes the client
jolt and sometimes flee clients refrain
from getting a cleaning session if they
have witnessed the cleaning session of
the previous client ending badly
cleaners give the impression of trying
to maintain a good reputation because
they cheat less when they see a big
audience or a long queue of clients
watching cleaners sometimes work as male
female teens and when the smaller female
cheats and bites the client the larger
male chases her off as if to punish her
for having tarnished their reputation an
amazing case of business savvy animals
in this underwater beauty salon
what fish mainly think about is food and
the pursuit of staying alive but the way
they plan and go about life shows that
they are capable of intelligence and
while you're watching this video your
goldfish is only getting smarter I hope
that knowledge that fish are not just
inanimate floating pieces of flesh
causes you to imagine they're more
complexly and change the way you treat
marine life and the ocean